the Joe Rogan experience also in you
this must be a personal thing for you
but it says the unfunniest time in
American history like yes no because you
rewarded for for stepping outside the
box that's true in a big way mm-hmm like
yeah you mean Dave Chappelle gets
attacked but guess what he also gets
rewarded in a huge way run he goes on
stage now people go ape [ __ ] that's true
and part of the reason why they go
[ __ ] bonkers is because they know
that this guy doesn't give a [ __ ] and
he's one of the rare ones who doesn't
give a [ __ ] so when he goes up there you
know if he thinks something crazy about
whatever it is whatever protected group
or whatever idea that he's not supposed
to explore that's not gonna stop him at
all he's gonna tell you exactly what he
thinks about those things regardless of
all this woke blowback he's not he
doesn't care right so because of that
he's rewarded even more and same thing
with Bill burr same thing with a lot of
comics I experienced it with my own
jokes
sure did more controversial bits getting
people more fired up now they love it
because everyone's smothered their
smothered by human resources and
smothered by office politics and you're
smothered by social discourse
restrictions and he's don't feel like
you can express yourself any more this
is true and and and all people also
don't have a they feel like they're
being watched all the time yeah other
things like that kind of can't let it
all hang out anywhere right and so
that's yeah they they do feel incredibly
like repressed and under the gun yeah I
think that that's that's true yeah I
just I feel like it I mean I'm not a
comic but if but I just imagine it must
be a more challenging environment it's
more challenging but more rewarding to
my friend ari said it best he said this
is a great time for comedy because
comedy is dangerous again right that's
true yeah that's true yeah it's kind of
goes back to like a Lenny Bruce era
right yeah when when you could kind of
completely freak people out with a cup
of saying a couple of sure yeah for good
or bad your prior yeah well like you saw
it with like louis c.k right a louis
ck's under the microscope now that joke
that he made about parkland
is absolutely a louis c.k joke if you
followed him throughout his career what
was the joke again I'm sorry the joke
was why am i listening to these
parklands survivors why are you
interesting because you pushed some fat
kid in the way like see you're laughing
right like that is a louis c.k joke he's
saying something [ __ ] up you're not
supposed to say that is throughout his
goddamn career he's done that that's
what we're always done but after the you
know jerking off in front of women all
that stuff and him coming out and
admitting it and then taking a bunch of
time off now he's a target right now he
does something like that and they're
like oh he's alright now like no this is
what he's always done right he's always
taking this sort of contrarian outside
the box [ __ ] up but hilarious take on
things and that bit
unfortunately because it was released by
someone who made a YouTube video of it
he didn't get a chance to he was gone
for ten months and he had only done a
couple sets when he was fleshing these
ideas out I guarantee you he would have
turned that idea into a brilliant bit
but he never got the chance because it
was just it was set out there in the
wild when it was a baby it was mauled
down by wolves it needed to be immediate
oh right yeah I mean that's what a bit
of these bits they they grow and they
develop and that was a controversial
idea that we're supposed to think that
someone's interesting just cuz they
survived a tragedy and his take is like
no no no you're not interesting right
you're [ __ ] boring you're annoying get
off my get off my TV and a lot of us
have felt that way sure he just the way
he said it was easy to take and put in
you know out of context put it in quotes
and turn him into an [ __ ] well yeah
but that's what comedy is right it's
it's taking what people the the thoughts
that everybody has and vocalizing that
the end that's forbidden thing in a way
that people can kind of you know come
together over right I mean I think that
was a lot a lot of what Richard Pryor's
humor was about like he took a lot of
this or uncomfortable race problems
right and he just kind of put them out
there and both white people and black
people laughed at it yeah right and like
together you know and that that was what
was good about it yes but if you can't
if if people are afraid to vocal
those things that they think it's gonna
you know ruin their career mean I guess
you know that that makes it more
interesting right it's more hype more
high stakes but if you can navigate
those waters and get to the promised
land of the punchline it's even more
rewarding right but you just have to
explain yourself better you have to have
better points you have to have you have
to have a better structure to your
material where you while the the people
who may find your idea objectionable
they you you coax them like hold my hand
I'm gonna take you through the woods
we're gonna be okay right follow me and
boom isn't that funny
right right right but you have to
navigate it skillfully and you have to
navigate it thoughtfully and you have to
really have a point you can't have a
half-assed point but you can't have a
situation where it's fatal to be off by
a little bit I know like there was a
writer that I loved growing up a Soviet
writer named Isaac Babel Stalin ended up
shooting him what he gave a speech about
I think it was in 1936 you know - to a
Soviet writers collective and he said
you know people say that we don't have
as much freedom as we used to but
actually all of all that the you know
the the Communist Party is done is
Britain is prevented us from writing
badly the only thing that's outlawed now
is writing badly all right and everybody
laughed but he was actually saying
something pretty serious which is that
you can't write well unless you can you
know screw up too you know like on the
way to to being creative in a good way
you have to miss yes you know and if
missing is not allowed and there's high
punishment for missing you're not going
to get art yeah you're not gonna get
revolution you're not gonna get all
these things well and in comedy it's
particularly important because you have
to work it out in front of people
absolutely yeah no I used to sit at a
comedy club in Manhattan when I was like
in college you know they would try out
their material like on a Wednesday right
you know early and that was always the
most interesting time for me well I can
they're trying stuff out and a lot of it
wasn't so good but you know it was
interesting right and you just can't
have a situation where people feel like
you know one wrong or
gonna ruin their careers yeah you know
yeah I don't know there's also people
that are wolves and they're trying to
take out that little baby joke wandering
through the woods they they want that
feeling of being able to take someone
down right and that that's you know
that's you're getting that now too which
is just and so now because that there's
like yonder bags at the improv where I'm
performing tonight they usually on their
bags you have to put yourself on the bag
when you go in there so you can't record
things yonder bag yes it's a company
called yonder it's just so strange it's
like all the shows I did with your pal
he uses yonder bags and an idea is to
prevent people from from filming and
recording and you know and then
eventually putting your stuff out there
well
[Applause]